[Music]
according to legend once every thousand
years a host of sea monsters emerges
from the depths to demand tribute from
the floating city of Atlanta Rica as the
ruler of the city you'd always dismissed
the stories until today when seven
leviathan lords rose out of the roiling
waters and surrounded your city each
commands ten giant kraken and each
kraken is accompanied by twelve mer
mites your city's puny army is
hopelessly outmatched you think back to
the legends in the stories the ruler of
the city saved his people by feeding the
creatures a ransom of pearls the pearls
would be split equally between the
leviathan lords each leviathan would
then divide its share into eleven equal
piles keeping one and giving the other
ten to their Kraken commanders each
Kraken would then divide its share into
13 equal piles keeping one and
distributing the other twelve to their
mer might minions if any one of these
divisions left an unequal pile or
leftover pearl the monsters would pull
everyone to the bottom of the sea such
was the fate of your fabled sister city
you rush to the ancient treasure room
and find five chests each containing a
precisely counted number of pearls
prepared by your ancestors for exactly
this purpose each of the chests bears a
number telling how many pearls it
contains unfortunately the symbols they
used to write digits 1,000 years ago
have changed with time and you don't
know how to read the ancient numbers
with hundreds of thousands of pearls in
each chest
there's no time to recount one of these
chests will save your city and the rest
will lead to its certain doom which do
you choose
there isn't enough information to decode
the ancient and Plante Arctic and
numeral system but all hope is not lost
because there's another piece of
information those symbols contain
patterns if we can find a matching
pattern in Arabic numerals we can still
pick the right chest let's take stock of
what we know a quantity of pearls that
can appease the sea monsters must be
divisible by 7 11 and 13 rather than
trying out numbers at random
let's examine ones that have this
property and see if there are any
patterns that unite them being divisible
by 7 11 and 13 means that our number
must be a multiple of 7 11 and 13 those
three numbers are all prime so
multiplying them together will give us
their least common multiple 1001 that's
a useful starting place because we now
know that any viable offering to the sea
monsters must be a multiple of 1001
let's try multiplying it by a
three-digit number just to get a feel
for what we might get if we try 861
times 1001 we get 860 1861 and we see
something similar with other examples
it's a peculiar pattern why would
multiplying a three-digit number by 1001
end up giving you two copies of that
number written one after the other
breaking down the multiplication problem
can give us the answer 1001 times any
number X is equal to 1000 X plus X for
example 725 times 1,000 is 725 thousand
and seven hundred 25 times 1 is 725 so
725 times 1,001 will be the sum of those
two numbers 725,000 725 and there's
nothing special about 725 pick any three
digit number and your final product will
have that many thousands plus one more
even though you don't know how to read
the numbers on the chests you can read
which patter
of digits represents a number divisible
by 1001 as with many problems trying
concrete examples can give you an
intuition for behavior that may at first
look abstract and mysterious the
monsters accept your ransom and swim
back down to the depths for another
thousand years with the proper planning
that should give you plenty of time to
prepare for their inevitable return and
if you'd like to hone your
problem-solving in the meantime check
out brilliant brilliance website and app
have more than 60 courses in math logic
science and computer science
they feature storytelling code writing
interactive challenges and plenty of
puzzles for you to solve
visit brilliant org slash ted-ed to
check it out and as an added bonus the
first eight hundred thirty three of you
to use that link will receive 20% off
the annual premium subscription fee